une fillette malienne de trois mois
décédé des suites d'une hémorragie
hémorragie consécutive à une excision d
excision réalisé avis sur le sol
français au début des années 80 les
milliers de cas sont recensés sur le
territoire des fillettes ou des femmes
victimes de l'ablation partielle ou
totale du clitoris un rituel ancestral
essentiellement africains perpétuer en
france par certaines familles
c'est-à-dire de parole dans un foyer les
travailler avant se regroupent et donc
des familles ils vont payer un billet
d'avion comment ils vont faire venir cet
matrone ils vont les salaires varient
elle sera logée nourrie juste content
bombay les célébrations sur à cette
époque si des parents avaient déjà été
condamnés pour avoir fait exciser leurs
filles
aucun texte non cadres est vraiment
cette pratique en france dans les années
90 la législation évoluer cette
mutilation sexuelle est désormais
considéré comme un délit passible de 10
ans de prison et de 150000 euros
d'amande et si la victime est mineure
elle devient un crime passible de 15 à
20 ans de réclusion criminelle
une répression que les associations
espèrent éviter en sensibilisant les
familles c'est pas la religion qu'ils
imposent donc je suis sûr qu'avec ne
serait ce qu'avec cette argumentation en
arriver là une femme sexy pour éradiquer
cette coutume le top model katusha
excisée à l'âge de 9 ans brise est aussi
le silence
en 2007 elle expliqué pourquoi la france
comptait encore autant de femmes
excisées grecques ont émis certaines
personnes en prison en france à la suite
de cette pratique
maintenant on les emmène les petites
filles durant les grandes vacances
on les met au nord mais elles reviennent
et personne n'a rien vu par son envie
rien donc ça continue pour se
reconstruire certaines femmes optent
pour une chirurgie réparatrice proposé
par des hôpitaux spécialisés en 2009
cette victime avait espoir de retrouver
une partie de sa féminité
je me sens privé de quelque chose en
fait je ne sens pas une femme mais pas
vraiment fait plein de charme on sur une
course et ça n'a par chance c'est comme
c'est comme si comme s'il y avait un an
c'est sous voilà un viol sont bien que
plupart chez moi je me suis je dit
malgré les lois les campagnes de
sensibilisation
l'horreur de l'excision perdure encore
pour près de 60000 française selon le
gouvernement dans le monde elles sont
entre 100 et 140 millions
[Musique]